Hey everyone!  Dr. Byrd here and we are going to kick off this series by first talking about what the price elasticity of demand is. We'll get into how we calculate later.
So, what is it?
The price elasticity of demand measures their responsiveness of quantity demand when there's a change in price. We write it like this.
The percentage change in price over the percentage change in quantity demand. We might also write it like this PED for price elasticity of demand. Okay. What does this mean? Quite simply if a firm increases its price by some percentage
then we expect quantity demand to fall by some percentage. Sounds great! But how much? That's where the elasticity comes into play. Let's say that we estimated the price elasticity of demand to be 2. This tells us that for a 10% increase in price we can expect quantity demand to fall by 20%. We simply multiply the increase in price by the elasticity of demand. One thing to note is that the elasticity of demand, by convention, is going to be some negative number and that's because the demand curve is downward sloping. So the increase in price
is going to cause us to have a decrease in the quantity demand which is why we have a decreased by 20% there. Cool right?
What about a price elasticity of demand that is equal to 0.5?
Here let's assume the firm lowers their price by 10%.
What's going to happen to quantity demand now? Quantity demand increases to 5%. The 10% times the .5. So we don't get as big of a response here like what we did in the previous case.
What does this mean?
That we simply don't get the same level of response because elasticities come in all shapes and sizes. Let's first look at this graph
Let's draw in a demand curve.
Where the price is on the vertical axis the quantity on the horizontal axis. And our demand curve is downward sloping.
Up here at some price level, we'll call this P1, we have Q1 as our quantity. Down here we have some price, we'll call it P2 and our quantity will be Q2.
At price P1 we're going to have the elasticity of demand equal to 2 at P2 we're going to have the elasticity of demand be equal to 0.5.
Now let's raise the price on P1 to P3.
And you see the response is going to be Q1 to Q3.
And let's also raise the price from P2 to P4.
And you can see the response is going to be Q4. Q2 to Q4. So what we have done is made a 10% increase in price from P2 to P4.
And we've made a 10% increase in price from P1 to P3. But notice the difference between Q1 and Q3 and Q4 in Q2 is different even with the same percentage change in price. That's because the elasticity of demand at 2 is greater than the elasticity of demand at 0.5.
All this simply means is that when the elasticity of demand increases we can expect bigger percentage change, prices uhh, bigger percentage changes in quantity demand.
All right so what can we do with this? Hold that thought. Let's first consider the different types of price elasticity of demand.
The price elasticity of demand comes in 5 varieites. Tthe first is perfectly inelastic.
The second is inelastic.
The third is going to be unit elastic.
And the 4th will be elastic.
And the fifth will be perfectly
elastic.
Perfectly elastic. We already know that the price elasticity can vary long a demand curve. But when a demand curve is affected by things other than the price you get varying slopes. Let's look at the first one.
Here we're going to draw our demand curve back in and when we look at the first one we have a perfectly inelastic--we're going to denote this as PI--a perfectly inelastic demand curve. Here the demand curve is vertical. As the price changes there is no change in quantity demand. So we will start at price P1 and we will go to price P2 and quantity demand does not change. Have you ever heard someone say money is no object?
They likely exhibit perfectly inelastic demand for a product. We can charge as much or as little as we want and there will be no change with quantity.
The next one is going to be perfect, uhm is going to be inelastic demand. This one is going to be a demand curve that is relatively steep but not vertical like the perfectly inelastic demand curve. This type of demand curve has an elasticity of demand that is going to be between 0 and 1. Any change in price is met by a less than that percent change in quantity. Meats, vegetables, grains, gas and good friendships are examples here. Next is unit elastic.
It has a uniform curve shape throughout. We'll denote this D with a little UE, unit elastic.
Heer any change in price is exactly matched by a change in quantity. Its price elasticity of demand is equal to 1.
Next up is elastic demand. It has a shape that's a little bit more flat than what we had previously seen. We'll label this D with a little subscript E.
We will see a bigger response in quantities demand when prices changes by some amount. Let's say price increase by 2%, then we'd expect quantity to fall by more than 2%. Here the price elasticity is going to be greater than 1 and less than infinity. A lot of household items—like name brand stuff—fall under this category.    Lastly, we have perfectly elastic demand and that is denoted by a horizontal demand curve. This is perfectly
elastic.
Dear Annie change in price, increase or decrease, will be met by a complete drop in quantity demand. Yep! That's right! If a firm tries to raise its price by 1% then they should expect to have no customers. This gives us that horizontal demand curve.
This is a special case and one we explore more later in this course.   Alright. That's it for this one. We'll catch you in the next one.